IT’S TIGHTER THAN IT HAS BEEN.
THANKS SO MUCH.
JOE BIDEN WILL SOON BE ON HIS
WAY TO NASHVILLE FOR THE FINAL
DEBATE.
THE FIRST TIME WE’VE SEEN THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE SINCE SUNDAY.
IS THAT THE RIGHT STRATEGY?
I WANT TO TALK TO OHIO
CONGRESSMAN AND BIDEN SURROGATE
TIME
TIM RYAN.
THANKS SO MUCH.
SO THE VICE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
PREPPING.
YOU THINK HE’S READY?
>> NO QUESTION.
I THINK IT’S GOING TO BE A LOT
BETTER NOW WITH THE MICROPHONE
SITUATION.
HE’S GOING TO ACTUALLY EXPLAIN
HIS POSITIONS AROUND PRESERVING
MEDICARE AND SOCIAL SECURITY AND
THE WHOLE BUILD BACK BETTER
PLAN, WHICH A LOT OF AMERICANS
WILL BE EXCITED ABOUT, ABOUT
BRINGING MANUFACTURING BACK,
FOCUSING ON MAKING THINGS IN
AMERICA AGAIN.
IT’S GOING TO BE GOOD.
HE WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GET THAT MESSAGE OUT.
SO WE’RE PSYCHED UP AND READY TO
GO FOR THIS ONE.
>> Dana: YOU MENTIONED THE
ECONOMY.
WE DO HAVE THE NEW FOX POLL.
IN THE BATTLEGROUND STATES, ON
THE ECONOMY, WHO DO YOU TRUST
BETTER?
BIDEN VERSUS TRUMP?
IN YOUR STATE, TRUMP DEFINITELY
IS UP AHEAD.
52 TO 41%.
TIED IN MICHIGAN.
PENNSYLVANIA, TRUMP IS UP BY 5.
IN WISCONSIN UP BY SEVEN.
IS THERE SOMETHING THAT THE VICE
PRESIDENT CAN DO TONIGHT TO TRY
TO KNOCK PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
NUMBERS DOWN A BIT?
>> WELL, I THINK JUST CONTINUING
HIS MESSAGE HERE IN OHIO HAS
BEEN LOOK, WE NEED TO BUILD BACK
BETTER.
WORKING CLASS PEOPLE WERE
STRUGGLING EVEN BEFORE
CORONAVIRUS.
HOW DO WE DO THINGS THAT ARE
GOING TO BRING MANUFACTURING
BACK?
WE’RE GOING TO BUILD ELECTRIC
VEHICLES, BUILD CHARGING
STATIONS, BUILD BATTERIES.
THESE ARE HUGE INVESTMENTS THAT
WILL CREATE MILLIONS OF JOBS IN
THE UNITED STATES.
BY ALL ACCOUNTS, BIDEN HAS A
GREAT PLAN THAT ALL THE
ECONOMISTS AND --
>> Dana: HE HAS YET TO MAKE A
DENT IN THE PRESIDENT’S NUMBERS
ON THE ECONOMY SO FAR.
>> WELL, I’VE SEEN POLLS THAT
HAVE HAD THEM NECK AND NECK,
TOO.
YOU’VE TALKING ABOUT A COUPLE
POLLS THERE.
I’VE SEEN POLLS THAT HAVE HIM
NECK AND NECK.
HERE’S THE KICKER.
THIS ECONOMY IS GOING NOWHERE
UNTIL YOU GET THE VIRUS UNDER
CONTROL.
I THINK JOE BIDEN’S NUMBERS ON
WHO IS BETTER HANDLING THE
VIRUS, HE HAS A HUGE LEAD
AGAINST TRUMP.
SO YEAH, MAYBE HE HAS SOME
ADVANTAGE THERE BUT YOU’RE NOT
GETTING TO THE ECONOMY UNTIL YOU
TAKE CARE OF THE VIRUS.
THAT’S WHY BIDEN IS DOING WELL
IN MANY OF THESE POLLS.
>> Dana: CONGRESSMAN, WE KNOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL BRING UP
EVEN IF THE MODERATOR DOESN’T,
THE NEW DEVELOPMENTS WITH REGARD
TO HUNTER BIDEN’S E-MAILS AND
TRY TO PAINT JOE BIDEN AS A
CORRUPT POLITICIAN.
SAY THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE ANSWERS.
DO YOU THINK THAT JOE BIDEN WILL
PROVIDE ANY ANSWERS ON THIS?
SO FAR THE STRATEGY SEEMS TO
HAVE BEEN TO DISMISS THE WHOLE
ISSUE OUT OF HAND.
>> WELL, IT’S BEEN DISMISSED BY
TWO REPUBLICAN-LED SENATE
COMMITTEES.
THIS IS GOING NOWHERE.
I THINK IT SHOWS THAT THE
PRESIDENT NEEDS TO SHAKE THIS
RACE UP IN SOME WAY AND HE’S
GOING TO SAY WHATEVER HE HAS TO
SAY.
IF YOU’RE GOING BACK TO A LAPTOP
THAT WAS LEFT SOMEWHERE THAT WE
DON’T EVEN REALLY KNOW WHOSE IT
WAS, YOU’RE REALLY IN THE LAST
TEN, 11, 12 DAYS OF THE CAMPAIGN
FOR PRESIDENT AND YOU’RE
STRETCHING TO TRY TO MAKE
SOMETHING HAPPEN THERE.
PEOPLE KNOW JOE BIDEN.
THEY KNOW HE’S NOT CORRUPT.
HE’S BEEN IN OFFICE.
HE’S BEEN A SENATOR.
HE CAME OUT OF THE SENATE.
THEY KNOW WHO HE IS.
>> Dana: I THINK THAT’S PROBABLY
WHY THE PRESIDENT WILL ASK HIM.
>> THE FOCUS -- HE’S GOING TO
FOCUS ON WHAT HE’S GOING TO DO
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND STOP
BRINGING UP THESE CORRUPTION
CHARGES.
WE COULD BRING UP A BUNCH OF
CORRUPTION CHARGES --
>> Dana: DEMOCRATS HAVE ACCUSED
PRESIDENT TRUMP OF ALL SORTS OF
THINGS.
THEY ACCUSED HIM OF ALL SORTS OF
THINGS FOR A WHILE.
LAST QUESTION.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
NOT JUST FOR THE PEOPLE OF OHIO
BUT ALSO OF THIS COUNTRY.
WHERE ARE YOU ON THIS COVID
RELIEF BILL?
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE A DEAL GET
DONE BEFORE THE ELECTION?
>> I WOULD.
I THINK WE NEED A DEAL DONE
IMMEDIATELY.
BUT IT CAN’T BE A BLANK CHECK
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION AND
EVERYONE NEEDS TO BE INCLUDED IN
IT.
YOU CAN’T JUST INCLUDE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND LEAVE OUT PEOPLE
THAT ARE UNEMPLOYED.
YOU CAN’T DO JUST UNEMPLOYED AND
LEAVE OUT SMALL BUSINESSES.
WE’RE ALL AMERICANS --
>> Dana: YOU THINK NANCY PELOSI
HAS PLAYED THIS WRONG?
YOU THINK THAT THE SPEAKER HAS
PLAYED THIS WRONG AND DRAGGED IT
ON WAY TOO LONG WHEN YOU HAD
SOME REPUBLICANS AND EVEN THE
PRESIDENT SAYING THEY WOULD BE
WILLING TO MAKE A DEAL?
>> WELL, THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
ALL OVER THE BOARD ON THIS
THING.
DEPENDS ON THE DAY, DEPENDS ON
THE TWEET.
I THINK --
>> Dana: TAKE HIS LAST OFFER AT
2.2 TRILLION.
>> IF IT’S 2.2 TRILLION, IT’S
GOING TO EVERYBODY AND EVERY
DOLLAR STAYS IN ITS LANE, THEN I
THINK WE SHOULD MAKE THAT DEAL.
BUT LET’S BE HONEST, THE LAST
TWO VERSIONS THAT HAVE COME --
THIS THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT
DURING THE NEGOTIATIONS WERE
BLANK CHECKS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THEY COULD
SPEND HOW THEY SEE FIT.
THAT’S NOT HOW WE’RE GOING TO DO
THIS.
WITH THE CONGRESS GOVERNS, THE
PRESIDENT IS A PART OF THAT.
THE CONGRESS GOVERNS.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WORKING CLASS PEOPLE ARE -- WE
HAVE EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE THAT
HAVE FALLEN INTO POVERTY.
>> Dana: I AGREE.
I WITH YOU.
WE HAVE TO DO MORE.
AND I THINK -- YOU AND I AGREE